first of all I want to talk about this
dress this is hot this is hot
this is Slayer hot for you this is our
little Joey King she's all grown ups
tell me about her I'm wearing custom
Jason whoo yeah custom honey that's him
baby I'm very excited about this look I
haven't done anything like simple and
just sexy before so I'm just happy to
just kind of wear something that feels
like natural and the wet hair yeah the
weapon I took my extensions out this is
all me now I don't want to kind of give
you some bad news but bad things tend to
happen in threes I know okay so you got
hit in the head at the Globes Critics
Choice Awards
you made the airwaves in a big way for
et we showed you when you had zipped up
you showed up the drought and I told
about that my dress busted open so uh-oh
I like the night is young you don't I
mean nothing so far
but there's like okay I don't know
what's gonna happen today nervous when I
saw you arrive I thought what horrible
thing has happened to Joey King today so
far like I like me I'm just I've been
super like careful about everything I
just had a thought when I was in the car
and I was lying down like so the dress
wouldn't ring cologne almost like what
if I like rip it it was like no I
haven't taken my photos yet so anything
the night is young I love it Critics
Choice how you freaked out like the rest
of the world over hot grease Andrew
Scott baby he is he's a dreamboat he's
not just hot priest he's Moriarty he's
he's the best actor ever I love him I
know I talked to you about this but I
wanted to ask you you're sort of
crushing all the different areas and the
fact that you brought wrong cons and
singularly back to Netflix like could we
see you doing more of it I know you're
gonna do another one but like I love
this for you I want more like I want you
to be what JLo was to be in the 90s like
I just want to watch you fall in love
with all the kinds of guys you are
um I don't know I'm not like opposed at
all to doing more rom-com I am I'm a I'm
what it's like what is it I'm trying to
think of that word that people use with
an expression where it's like I'm a bird
you got to let me fly I don't know
something like that I'm not married
Jenny Chandra I love all genres
I'm a bird I'm a peacock that's what it
is I'm a peacock you gotta let me fly
it's from that movie the other guys with
Will Ferrell and marquel anyway whatever
okay
good luck tonight Godspeed in your
tragedies me thank thank you I believe
in you I believe you can get through
tonight oh yeah well she told me the
secret she she's never done it but can I
see the shoe yeah yeah oh she's got a
platform just SuperDuper high unnatural
angle half CBD cream on my feet platform
that's the secret that's a secret I've
never tried it before so well I mean so
far so good
Crafton like is there is this a course
in them but yeah this is all corseted
this is I had like no lunch for you my
mom was like super stoked on like today
being like special so she got a bunch of
pastries this morning and I was like mom
like what do you like what and then I
ate all of them you're like it's not a
pastry well I'm fine yeah you know what
whatever
[Music]